alright guys so if you watched my
previous video on apple silicon mac
gaming
you'll know how confident i am that
apple's transition
from intel chips to their own apple
silicon chips
on their mac computers is gonna be huge
for gaming and we know this thanks to
the massive amount of times apple
mentioned brand new gaming changes
in their wwdc 2020 developer videos
including full-fledged game controller
support
cross-platform multiplayer gaming
keyboard and mouse gaming with pointer
locking
coming to the ipad and of course iphone
and ipad games coming to apple silicon
max on day one
the main downside to all of this is that
windows 10 gaming using bootcamp is
going away
thanks to the switch to arm-based apple
silicon chips
and that's why we've still been
recommending intel-based macs like the
16-inch macbook pro
currently on sale for only 2100 on
amazon right now for users who want to
continue
playing those windows games and that's
because there's a fairly low chance that
the current
x86 aaa windows games that you know and
love
are going to be ported over to apple
silicon max but there's actually a
really awesome solution
to this problem but first let me mention
our new
apple product pattern t-shirts that you
can find down below in our merch shelf
thanks to a comment made by flame sword
300
i just discovered that users who want to
buy an apple silicon mac later this year
but also want to play windows 10 games
now have a very good
solution to this problem and that's the
new
shadow game streaming service but this
isn't like any other cloud game
streaming service out there
like geforce now playstation now or
google stadia
shadow actually allows you to stream a
fully featured gaming pc
to all of your devices including your
iphone
your ipad your apple tv and your mac
and before we move further i want to
mention that shadow is not
sponsoring this video and we're not
affiliated with them in
any way the reason i'm excited about it
is because it's totally unique
unlike other platforms like stadia which
allow you to stream
from their game library shadow gives you
an
entire windows operating system to use
as you see
fit so you can play any game on windows
10
with no limits so if you purchase a game
on steam
it's yours forever even if you cancel
your shadow subscription
this works basically the same way as if
you had an intel
mac and you used bootcamp to game on
windows 10. now you might be wondering
how am i so certain that shadow is going
to run on apple silicon max
well shadow's own ios developer thomas
spent hours reading through published
press articles
about apple's wwdc 2020 event
and his conclusion is that the new
features apple is adding this year
are going to greatly improve gaming
specifically cloud gaming using shadow
there's now finally full mouse support
for every type of game in ios
ipad os 14 and even tv os 14
with the most important feature being
cursor locking
for games like league of legends
overwatch and call of duty
which is a monumental advancement for
game
inclusivity he then mentioned that the
new update allows shadow
to add trackpad support for the new ipad
keyboards
and apple went even further by allowing
support for
every single button that a mouse can
have even a mouse like this one
from razer he mentioned that the new
update will allow for notifications in
the shadow app
for when a mouse has been plugged in or
connected using bluetooth
he also talked about gamepad support
saying that we should be able to use
all third-party gamepads and it even
supports
the ps4 controller touchpad and all of
the buttons on the xbox elite 2
controller there's even rumble
battery level and controller color
support
apple also added support for performance
intensive apps and games
in the new update as well basically
these new changes from apple this year
will greatly improve the overall
experience for shadow users
once they're able to implement the new
features and he finished by saying the
future of iphone
ipad and apple tv is bright on shadow
and that we're now in a whole new
ballgame thanks to ios and ipad os 14.
and you can bet that shadow is also
coming to apple silicon max
especially since they'll be able to run
unmodified ios and ipad apps on
day one and shadow will obviously
continue support
for the mac going into the future now
perhaps the best part about all of this
is the price
starting at only 12 dollars a month with
the option to upgrade the storage
from the base 256 gig ssd this base
cloud pc
will come with a 3.4 gigahertz 4 core
cpu
12 gigs of ram and a gtx 1080 graphics
card or better and the best part is that
shadow has been
optimized for most connections even 4g
lte and even better it's not limited to
just
gaming you can use your shadow cloud pc
to do anything you can regularly do on a
windows pc
like editing 4k video or doing other
professional work
so i hit the pre-order button and it
says that if i order it right now
it should be activated and available for
me to use
this september shadow also has the ultra
and
infinite options for 25 dollars a month
or 40 dollars
which includes better systems with
higher performance graphics cards like
the rtx 2080
or titan rtx that support 4k with ray
tracing but unfortunately
shadow just released a statement saying
that pre-orders of those high-end
systems
are delayed until early 2021 but that's
actually when
a lot of people are going to be buying
the new apple silicon max
and this will give them extra time to
update shadow to support
all of those new gaming features that
apple is adding this year
and for the time being those who want
the higher end systems can simply use
the standard
12 a month version of shadow which comes
with
a gtx 1080 graphics card so what i want
to do is compare the price of shadow
to the current option of gaming on the
mac by far
the best and most cost effective way of
windows 10 gaming on the mac right now
is buying a 13-inch macbook pro and an
egpu setup
using bootcamp to run windows 10 and in
our experience
the best option for an egpu is the razer
core x
enclosure and a 5700 xt graphics card
for a total of 680
on amazon but because of the
inefficiencies that come with using
egbus
we got a geekbench 5 graphics score of
around 55
to 58 000 points in the best case
scenario
compared to around 53 000 points for the
gtx 1080.
so it should give you a fairly similar
experience albeit not as good but pretty
close
especially if you don't play at high
graphic settings so if you take that
same 680
that we've spent on the egpu setup and
use it to pay for the base version of
shadow
that'll get you over four and a half
years of windows 10 pc
gaming over the cloud on any of your
apple devices
including the future apple silicon max
of course
users are likely to upgrade to more
storage or to the better shadow systems
but if you want to switch to an apple
silicon mac but don't want to give up
your current gaming library on windows
10
this is actually going to be the perfect
overall solution
and the reason is perfect is because
it's totally different
from all of the other cloud gaming
services and the developers of shadow
are extremely excited and ready to adopt
all of the new gaming features
that apple is bringing to their devices
so if you're the type that
hates mobile gaming and you're not
excited to play
those games on the very first apple
silicon max
you now have a really great option
instead of being forced to stick with an
intel based mac to play games on windows
10. if this video helped you out go
ahead and tap the like button and click
the circle
above to subscribe definitely go down
and check out our merch
and right over there you'll find our
apple silicon max explained playlist
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
you